I'm kind of like you you know like
real similar upbringing didn't really
have like a dad around kind of had like
a mean mom thanks for calling Chris
thanks for sharing let's hear more
so about like my feelings or whatever
how to talk to girls basically how to
express my feelings towards girls so ah
man that was the bane of my existence I
didn't realize it until recently that
that was what caused a lot of uh my
issues with us that I couldn't I just
couldn't really I couldn't I was afraid
to talk to women and that fear just
resonated inside of me let's hear more
I always kind of had like a upset that I
was too nice she was running around with
my friends after that
okay she had a girlfriend she was too
nice but then she you were too nice and
she started running around with your
friends let's hear more
and uh that kind of like made me want to
change myself so I started to try to be
a little bit more edgy started drinking
started smoking started partying and
that worked you know I I got a little
bit more popular but it didn't really
help like with girls I mean
you know most of the time I would end up
like sleeping in the bushes or something
like that instead of you know getting a
girl yeah so you weren't getting the
girls so you started being a certain way
oh I need a drink more I need to you
know use drugs or do something but to
get the girls yep that's most dudes so
that's okay uh but yeah I was exactly
that way man I didn't know who I was so
I just knew that whatever I was wasn't
okay because women didn't like me
um and the main reason that I felt that
way was because probably in hindsight I
felt like somewhere inside of me I felt
like my mother didn't really like me
probably I know that's a big jump for
some people listening to this but that's
you know as I learned more about myself
I realized that I never
you know that if I thought my mother
didn't like me you know and I didn't
feel that relationship with her then I
didn't really know how to relate to
women because that's your first
relationship for a young man and if my
relationship with her was kind of
damaged then
you know my relationship with all women
was probably gonna be at least
you know off to a rocky start because I
didn't know even how to begin one
so once women weren't recognizing me
well or wasn't working then uh then yeah
of course you adjusted yourself you
party and now you smoking you laying in
the bush as you live in life let's hear
more
to come home with me
um and I just kept escalating and my
mother wasn't having it you know she
she ended up kicking me out the house
after that I ended up living in a shed
for about
six months
um and that's when things really got
dark
um and this kind of a you know a tough
call to hear I'm sure on a Monday or
whatever some of you guys are still uh
you know if you guys are listening to
the episode but
um you know this is life man and this is
what's going on and and Chris called
about 10 days ago and this call really
meant a lot to me because it you know I
really I could relate to this a lot
Chris I could relate to a lot of the
things you're sharing because I felt a
lot of these same ways you know I didn't
all I wanted to do was feel the
affections of a woman somehow and not
even sexual I just wanted a woman to
think that I was okay because for some
reason when I was a kid something I
don't know what happened I don't know it
was before I was even able to know what
was going on
I felt like I my mother some our
connection was not good and I felt
somewhere like I was not okay with she
didn't think I was okay or something was
not okay she did not accept me or I felt
unaccepted by her so immediately then
every other woman I immediately meet I
already feel unaccepted by them so then
I changed myself I start being different
ways acting outlandish acting this way
being loud being goofy whatever
something
something to
to alter that interaction that has
something to try any code I could to
crack
to crack this comfortability with women
and make it feel more comfortable
um and then yeah and my mom and I's
relationship of course was never really
getting strong I got emancipated
I went out was living with friends
thankfully I didn't have to live in a
shed
um you know I was pretty blessed that I
had some good friends and different
families that took me in but let's hear
more about your story I'm just saying
it's right alongside let's go
you know I had always
kind of depressed because you know I
didn't really have like a person in my
life like I was I was alone basically so
um when I was in that shed things got
real dark you know I I uh would just
stay up all night doing drugs and
um porn probably four times a day maybe
more than that Jeepers dude
oh if I have to watch porn twice in it I
feel horrible or I don't even do it but
I'm you know I I'm a one-trick pony
anyway when it comes to sensuality
whether I'm doing self-pleasure or
actual sex if I'm doing sex let's hear
more
um and that went on for like six months
and um this was a year ago
Yeah man so I got like some dysfunction
going on with me
um
and uh the crazy thing is is that like
in order to heal myself and to get
better to do is to get out there and
meet somebody and get into a
relationship and start getting out there
um but it's hard because like I said I
don't have that drive I don't have the
libido I don't wake up in the morning
and just have that fire inside of me I
have low self-confidence
um just from you know I still kind of
see myself as like that Homeless dude
jerking off in the shed
yes you have a low your view of yourself
probably isn't always good it sounds
like man I'm sorry dude you know I
appreciate you telling you know sharing
this I really do
you know and I hope that by hearing this
back and listening to some of this
you're able to kind of get a little bit
you know maybe a it might be just a
little more perspective on yourself I
can relate to this hundred percent you
know I really can self-worth is low and
a lot of that probably you know and look
I gotta tell you I'm not legit I'm not
any therapist I have no idea the [__]
I'm talking about you know I don't have
any medical background I have no I the
only thing I know is that I can when you
tell me your story right there Chris
that I have heard your story or parts of
it inside of myself
you know and I've lived through some of
your story before maybe not exactly but
I have not heard had anyone call where I
could relate as much uh to someone call
and the thing that helped me I'll be
honest with you was getting into a
program dude it really did
um it helped me
it really helped me I don't know if you
need a program you know if you need a
you know an AAA or an N A or a CA I have
no idea
you know I don't know if I'll be
involved in that program forever but for
now I know that that program has helped
me get a better look at myself to know
who I really am
you know and it's hard man I've had to
learn slowly to be vulnerable in
relationships so that I can even build a
connection with a woman and this is slow
stuff dude it's slow and it takes work
but you can feel better I promise
you know that's all I can tell you man
is that you can feel better and
relationships that haven't been good or
whatever will get better and that
somebody can love you and you can love
somebody else and
um
you know and I can't tell you what you
know I I can't you know you can't tell
somebody to go get in a program but you
can just I can tell you that for me it's
changed my life
you know and sometimes it's hard for me
to even admit because sometimes I'm so
like self-centered or so
you know afraid to admit that anything
other than
me has changed my life because I'm so
used to doing everything for myself
you know but when I'm really honest
yeah man that program has changed my
life
um I have a constant base of men and
other people that I can go to every day
uh to
who to learn how to live in any moment
if I don't know something to do there's
somebody I can call there's 40 people I
can call say hey what do I do right now
and they're like this is what you do
and these are people that I trust and
know and love and I know that they love
me and Bam I do that because those are
the things you don't get when you don't
have like that relationship with a
mother relationship with the father you
don't get those
you don't have you don't know no one
ever teaches you anything
you know and it's hard to teach yourself
anything because you just you're so busy
just trying to survive you know so
sometimes it's hard to learn
uh but I love you man keep your head up
you know keep your head up dude
you get to your Paradise City man we all
going to get there whether it's somebody
that wants marijuana out there in North
Carolina
you know whether it's the guy in the
Pacific Northwest that just wants to be
able to share his feelings with a woman
but it's afraid even if you can't even
talk to a woman anymore about getting
shut down but I don't think that's going
to be forever man just we just gotta
just hold the line hold the line it's
okay we're gonna be okay
the man that's out there paying for gas
with change
do you want to be paying for gas with
dollars soon brother
but hey dude it's funny you called in
man you made me reminding me when I used
to pay for gas man rolling there with a
hot sock full of nickels
[__] drop them on the counter walk
out
that's their issue then you brought the
change but they gonna have to count that
[__] you know
but yeah it can be funny man laugh at
that [__] next time you paying
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one